parce que nos vies se transforme
perpétuellement nous avons le devoir de
recycler tous ces matériaux yprema votre
partenaire pour un développement durable
bonjour et bienvenue dans équilibre le
magazine de l'environnement et du
développement durable
au sommaire de ce numéro à saint cyr
l'école on peut louer des parcelles pour
cultiver hors sol ses propres fruits et
légumes
nous nous y sommes rendus à jouy en
josas une maison démontable a vu le jour
destinés à des personnes en difficulté
elle est aussi écologique des manies
quoi se sont donnés rendez vous 1 samedi
pour organiser un ramassage de déchets
dans leur jeu et leur sort et nous y
avons participé
mais tout d'abord au mois de mars et
avril la france et plus particulièrement
paris et la région francilienne ont
connu plusieurs épisodes de pollution
aux particules
rencontre avec deux chercheurs du
laboratoire des sciences du climat et de
l'environnement pour comprendre comment
et évaluer cette pollution et le diwan
pour les images en mars dernier la
france connait pendant plusieurs jours
un épisode de pollution très important à
plusieurs reprises le seuil d alerte de
pollution aux particules est franchie
100 % de la population yvelinoise
étaient concernés de quoi est constitué
notre atmosphère et d'où vient la
pollution pour le savoir direction du
laboratoire des sciences du climat et de
l'environnement en moyenne dans
l'atmosphère on a 50 % de carbone et 50%
diot le carbone c'est typiquement
pour avoir une image un peu précis c'est
typiquement
les particules noires qu'on peut
observer quand on fait soir
un barbecue soit un feu de cheminée
soit
les émissions que l'on voit des
particules que l'on voit qu'ils sortent
d'un pot d'échappement et
particulièrement à pot d'échappement
il avait vu deux fonctionnent au diesel
ces particules mise en cause ce sont les
pm10 les pm2 5 et les pme des catégories
d'études en fonction de la taille des
particules les pm10 et pm2 5 sont celles
réglementés au niveau français et
européen disent ça veut dire que l'on
regarde la fraction qui est inférieur à
10 microns c'est à dire qu'on va on va
prendre finalement que toutes les
particules qui sont dans
dans l'atmosphère
et on va dire ok on va ne regarder que
celles qui sont inférieures à 10 microns
quand on parle de pm de ça qu'on va
regarder celles qui sont inférieures à
2,5 microns et quand on parle de pm main
on va regarder cette liste sont
inférieurs à 1 micron les particules
pm10 sont six à huit fois plus petit que
l'épaisseur d'un cheveu
les particules fines ou pm2 5 peuvent se
loger dans les ramifications des voies
respiratoires lors des pics de mars les
particules pm10 sont atteints sans un
micro par mètre cube le vendredi 20 mars
le seuil d alerte défini par le
ministère et 2 80 microns par mètre cube
mais les particules ne sont pas les
seuls responsables de la pollution les
gaz sont aussi des polluants
l'ozone il est pas produit directement
dans l'atmosphère il faut décomposer
qu'on appelle précurseur donc les oxydes
d azote qui sont émis par le trafic et
les composés organiques volatils et
c'est ce mélange là qui va former nos
zones et l'ozone
on respire dans nos villes et surtout
autour de nos villes les foxes pour la
santé pour cette formation d'ozone il
faut combiner ces oxydes d azote qui
sont plutôt liées au trafic mais avec
d'autres composés et ses autres composés
vont être émis par différentes sources
mais aussi la végétation donc c'est pour
ça que des fois au niveau des forêts on
va se retrouver des niveaux importants
de bosnie en ile-de-france la qualité de
l'air est évalué par airparif en
complémentarité sur le plateau de saclay
la station cirta du laboratoire des
sciences du climat et de l'environnement
composé de trois chercheurs et trois
ingénieurs travaillent sur cette
problématique sur le long terme
ce laboratoire est le fruit d'une
collaboration entre le cea le cnrs et
l'université de versailles saint quentin
et l'institut national de
l'environnement industriel et des
risques
alors si on est dans un laboratoire de
recherche mais on travaille en
collaboration avec des organismes tels
que airparif
et aussi cette importance est un site
qui est labellisée au niveau national et
également au niveau européen on essaie
d'avoir des mesures homogène dans tous
ses laboratoires européens pour qu'elle
puisse être comparables et qu'elle
puisse être aussi ensuite être utilisés
dans la modélisation et est donc avoir
une vision d'ensemble de cette pollution
et parce que la pollution n'a pas de
frontières la station fait partie du
réseau actrice dans lequel une trentaine
de pays sont impliqués à saint cyr
l'école on peut dorénavant louer une
parcelle pour cultiver un jardin si on
n'en possède pas chez soi mais ces
terrains ne sont pas ordinaires au ferme
en ville on cultive hors sol un
reportage réalisé avec william el est
michael et me d'euros dernier assemblage
pour installer les parcelles des
potagers de gally les ferme en ville
proposent de louer votre propre surface
avec une petite particularité ici on
cultive hors sol on met de la terre au
dessus du sol
parce que on est sur une ancienne friche
qui était une décharge où il y avait des
polluants bon inerte mais dont on avait
un seul qui était totalement impropres à
la culture et qui était bon bah escarpé
donc on a dû remettre à niveau et
c'était de la terre qui n'était pas
forcément bonne pour faire des cultures
directement dessus
du coup on a décidé de remettre de la
terre au dessus de la terre initial pour
pouvoir cultiver mais pas de différence
avec la culture normal la terre proposé
ici est contrôlé basé sur le principe
des jardins partagés ces parcelles seul
ou 50 euros par mois à terme il y en
aura 90 la nouveauté en fait c'est que
nous en fait on a un maraîcher qui
essaie sur la zone qui travaillent qui
travaillent pour lui et que donc il va
leur apporter deux heures par mois des
conseils à tous
en plus de ça c'est des jardins qui sont
irriguées ça veut dire que donc il ya
pas obligatoirement de de présence pour
venir arroser ses plantes
ce qui est plutôt pratique en été on
peut partir deux semaines et laisser ces
plantes sans qu'elles sèchent quoi les
potagers de gally sont accessible 7
jours sur 7
ouverts jusqu'à 20 heures en période
estivale ils fermeront à 18 heures en
hiver une solution pour tous ceux qui
veulent cultiver leurs propres fruits et
légumes mais qui n'ont pas de jardin
chez eux pour pallier le problème de
logement en ile-de-france l'association
habitat et humanisme a imaginé une
maison montagne est démontable
construite entièrement en bois elle est
aussi écologique
elle vient d'être installé à jouy en
josas pour une durée de quatre ans
reportage dix jours deux étages trois de
démontage difficile à imaginer
c'est pourtant ce que sont parvenus à
réaliser des architectes d'une surface
de 40 mètres carrés cette maison peut
accueillir quatre personnes
c'est une vraie maison c'est à dire
c'est une maison qui est conforme à la
réglementation globale donc en normes du
code de la construction et autres qui
permet tout à fait de vivre dans des
conditions tout à fait classique d'une
maison standard modulable en fonction
des besoins des occupants grâce à ses
parois préfabriqués elle est entièrement
composée de bois un matériau certifié
pef ces labels garantissant la gestion
durable des forêts c'est parfait pour
l'isolation ces mêmes meilleur une
isolation en moque l'isolation de
produits issus de la chimie je dirais
puisqu'on a pas rentrer dans la
technique mais on a des notions de
confort qui sont beaucoup plus
performante effectivement un ensemble
complètement réemployables puisque sur
le filière bois le bois comme on le sait
c'est un produit qui peut être
complètement réemployer sous d'autres
formes ou à déchiqueter ou autre mais
cette maison est avant tout un projet
solidaire j'avais par l'association
habitat et humanisme sur un terrain
prêté par la commune de jeu
en josas elle a accueilli sa première
famille à la mi avril
on fait du logement temporaire
accompagné donc on accompagne des
ménages fragiles pendant en général deux
ans dans un logement classique aussi bas
une maison démontable pourquoi on ferait
pas notre métier dans une maison qui
elle même est temporaire cette maison
temporaire devrait accueillir deux à
trois familles dans les quatre ans à
venir avant d'être démontée et de
trouver un nouvel emplacement
je vous en parlais dans le numéro du
mois de janvier une application
lancèrent de file ses utilisateurs mais
aussi aux gens pour développer le
covoiturage maison entreprises ce défi a
pris fin il ya quelques jours je vous
propose d'écouter son fondateur
alors petit bilan donc without our ses
15000 personnes qui ont été impactés par
la communication on a à peu près de 200
nouveaux inscrits sur la plateforme c
environ 700 messages échangés et c'est
surtout 30 nouvelles personnes qui se
sont mis à covoiturer l'expression
nettoyage de printemps prend tout son
sens pour plusieurs commune yvelinoise
ces dernières organise des ramassages de
déchets nous avons participé à celle de
magny les hameaux et la nature de ce qui
a été récolté pourrait bien vous étonner
le beau temps n'était pas au beau fixe
ce matin là mais pas de quoi décourager
les 32 bénévoles manie quoi venu donner
un coup de propre alors commune sacs
poubelles gants et chaussures de marche
ils partent pour une heure sur deux
circuits forestier et un urbain je pense
qu'il ya plus de gens qui devraient
participer
moi je suis étonné qui est bon il ya
quand même déjà quand même pas mal de
monde mais j'aurais pensé qu'il ya plus
de gens
effectivement les poèmes c'est que c'est
la majorité qui qui jettent des papiers
des canettes ça et c'est pas eux qui
vont venir ramasser en fait papiers
bouteilles sont les principaux déchets
mais parfois les objets collectés sont
plus inhabituel mise en place depuis une
quinzaine d'années cette initiative
permet de compléter le travail des
équipes municipales les harris technique
le font à longueur d'année
mais on ne peut pas aller par exemple
dans les fossés dans les bas-côtés
entrer dans les dix premiers mètres de
la forêt voilà donc là les équipes
ramasse sur un peu plus large que les
bords de routes et de chemins les
détritus collectés ont ensuite été triés
puis envoyé en déchetterie ou au centre
de valorisation mais quoi qu'il en soit
la 200 du jour c'est lilian trois ans et
demi qui nous la donne valeur il faut
jeter comme chaque mois voici quelques
rendez vous si vous voulez découvrir la
biodiversité de l'étang des rousses hier
la randonnée organisée par la ville de
la verrière est fait pour vous pensez
juste à vous inscrire vous voulez
découvrir comment créer vos propres
produits d'entretien et de beauté tout
en restant écologique
le musée de la ville vous propose un
atelier le jeudi 23 avril c'est à partir
de l'âge de 6 ans pas de dates à retenir
cette fois mais une petite astuce le
ministère de l'écologie du développement
durable et de l'énergie et la dell ou
lancer un site pratique pour vous aider
à bien trier plus de 780 types de
déchets et 50 mille points de collecte
sont référencés vous n'avez plus le
droit de vous tromper
voilà équilibre c'est terminé je vous
donne rendez vous le mois prochain
d'ici là pensez à faire un geste pour
l'environnement